Mary here with a gamespot news update
it's been confirmed that fallout 4 will
be running at 1080p 30 frames per second
on ps4 xbox one and pc but bethesda is
already stomping out flames by saying
that pc has not been limited in any way
todd howard creative director at
bethesda game studios told Digital spy's
that the upcoming post-apocalyptic
open-world RPG is 1080p on everything
continuing to confirm that it would also
run at 30 frames per second as opposed
to 60 bethesda then clarified that while
the xbox one and ps4 versions of fallout
will run at 1080p and 30fps the
resolution and FPS are not limited in
any way on pc fallout was shown at
length during the festive III 2015 press
conference during the event Howard
appeared on stage and discussed two
games deep customization features showed
off the overhauled Pip Boy and revealed
the real-life spit boy will be available
with special editions of the game
Fallout floors official release date is
November 10 2 2015 for the latest on
fallout 4 be sure to check out the
coverage on gamespot com